Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
________________
LE CHRISTIANISME
« Nous sommes tous, nous autres Français,
des catholiques culturels ! »
— Frédéric Martel, Interview dans l’hebdomadaire
Le Point (2019)
Contrairement au judaïsme, dont je vous ai
parlé dans la leçon précédente, le christianisme
est, lui, fondé sur l’héritage d’un
seul individu : Jésus, qui, pour les chrétiens,
est à la fois le fils de Dieu et Dieu lui-même.
Son parcours et son enseignement ont été
retranscrits bien plus rapidement que ceux
des prophètes juifs, et si certains avaient
soutenu que Jésus était un personnage inventé,
son existence historique est aujourd’hui
avérée.
Ce que met en évidence Frédéric Martel,
qui est l’auteur de Sodoma, l’enquête
de référence sur l’homosexualité au Vatican,
c’est que le déclin de la religion chrétienne
en Occident ne lui enlève pas sa prééminence
dans la culture occidentale. Si les chrétiens
pratiquants sont devenus minoritaires, nous
vivons encore, sans en avoir conscience pour
la plupart d’entre nous, selon des coutumes,
des règles et des idées héritées d’époques
où le christianisme était l’idéologie
dominante, celle qui façonne la société.
L’imprégnation de la culture occidentale
par le christianisme est telle que je dois
d’ores et déjà vous prévenir : il est
impossible de tout synthétiser en une seule
vidéo ; je vais donc forcément commettre
des impasses, qu’il s’agisse de l’histoire
de Jésus et de ses disciples, de celle de
la diffusion de son enseignement (en Occident
et ailleurs), de celle de l’Église catholique,
des débats doctrinaux, ou encore de l’éventail
des divers rites qui rythment la vie des pratiquants.
Mais je vous rassure : si vous assimilez le
contenu de cette leçon, vous en saurez plus
sur le christianisme que 99 % des gens !
Je vous ai déjà donné quelques bases dans
la première leçon du module.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
* Comment le christianisme naît-il ?
* Que retenir de la Bible chrétienne ?
* Quelles sont les évolutions marquantes
du christianisme ?
* Qui sont les penseurs majeurs du christianisme
?
* Quelle est la situation actuelle du christianisme
Comment le christianisme naît-il ?
Je vais vous raconter la vie de Jésus, le
fondateur du christianisme ; je vais ensuite
vous synthétiser sa « philosophie » ; et
enfin, je vous expliquerai comment le christianisme
a réussi à se diffuser à partir de l’aventure
de Jésus.
Qui est Jésus ?
L’essentiel de ce que nous savons de sa
vie provient de sources chrétiennes, au premier
plan desquelles les 4 Évangiles de Matthieu,
Marc, Luc et Jean (dont je vais vous parler
dans la suite de la leçon). Il existe d’autres
sources — notamment les Antiquités juives
de l’historien juif du Ier siècle Flavius
Josèphe, ou les Annales de l’historien
romain du tournant du Ier siècle Tacite — mais
ces sources ne nous apprennent pas grand-chose.
L’exégèse scientifique, c’est-à-dire
l’interprétation scientifique de La Bible
— cette exégèse née à l’époque des
Lumières permet d’écrire une biographie
vraisemblable de Jésus.
En résumé, Jésus est un Juif né en Palestine
quelques années avant le début de notre
ère (même si elle commence théoriquement
avec sa naissance). Il a grandi dans une famille
de Juifs très pieux qui pratiquait la circoncision,
respectait le shabbat et allait en pèlerinage
au Temple pour les fêtes. Il a certainement
été à l’école de sa synagogue, avant
d’adopter le métier de son père, charpentier.
Il avait probablement des frères et sœurs
(ainsi que le soutient la tradition protestante),
mais l’hypothèse selon laquelle il était
marié est peu crédible, car les prédicateurs
itinérants de cette époque étaient célibataires.
C’est tout ce que nous savons des trente
premières années de la vie de Jésus, appelées
« les années cachées » par la tradition
chrétienne. Nous le connaissons surtout dans
son rôle de prédicateur, qu’il a tenu
entre 1 et 3 ans, jusqu’à sa mort.
Jésus était plus précisément un prophète
itinérant et indépendant — comme il en
existait des dizaines d’autres en son temps
— qui pratique exorcismes et guérisons,
prêche l’amour et la non-violence. Dans
Jesus the Magician, l’historien américain
Morton Smith montre que les exploits apparemment
surnaturels du fondateur du christianisme
sont étonnamment similaires aux opérations
« magiques » qu’on pratiquait dans l’Antiquité.
Sa thèse est que Jésus n’était pas un
prophète auquel on a ensuite attribué des
pouvoirs magiques, mais l’inverse, un magicien
dont on a fait un prophète.
« À cette période, un magicien pourrait
facilement être considéré
comme un prophète et une autorité de la
Loi. »
— Morton Smith, Jesus the Magician
Comment Jésus vit-il ? Il est entouré d’un
premier cercle de 12 hommes. Fait incongru,
il fréquente également des femmes que la
tradition juive cantonne pourtant au foyer,
qui plus est des marginales, des veuves, et
peut-être même des prostituées. Il impose
à ceux qui le suivent son mode de vie radical,
celui d’un vagabond qui méprise les biens
matériels.
Sur le plan religieux, il prend des libertés
avec la loi juive — il transgresse par exemple
le shabbat et le jeune — et il dénonce
l’application rigoriste des règles religieuses
par des hommes qui n’ont pas l’esprit
de la religion dans leur cœur. C’est cette
« dissidence » qui lui vaudra d’être
arrêté et condamné. Les prêtres ont probablement
décidé d’y mettre un terme après le fameux
épisode de l’expulsion des marchands du
Temple : scandalisé, Jésus renverse les
tables des marchands et des changeurs qui
travaillent dans l’enceinte sacrée. Il
s’agirait de l’unique cas où Jésus utilise
la force physique contre des hommes.
« Ma maison sera appelée une maison de prière.
Mais vous, vous en faites une caverne de voleurs.
»
— Matthieu, XXI, 12-13
Les évènements qui vont de l’arrestation
de Jésus à sa mort constituent ce qu’on
appelle la Passion du Christ (vous avez peut-être
vu le film éponyme de Mel Gibson de 2004).
En voici les étapes essentielles :
* La Cène (du latin cena, « repas du soir,
souper ») : à la veille de son arrestation,
Jésus réunit ses douze apôtres pour un
ultime repas, rompt le pain et partage le
vin selon la tradition juive, mais il y ajoute
deux phrases étranges, rapportées à plusieurs
reprises dans le Nouveau Testament :
« Prenez, mangez, ceci est mon corps »
— Jésus, en partageant le pain
Puis, en leur tendant la coupe de vin : « Ceci
est mon sang, le sang de l’alliance qui
va être répandu pour la multitude en rémission
des péchés ».
* La trahison de Judas : Judas, un des douze
apôtres, désigne Jésus aux autorités,
si bien qu’il est arrêté dans la nuit.
* La condamnation de Jésus : arrêté, il
est aussitôt conduit devant le Sanhédrin
(le tribunal suprême de la communauté juive,
composé d’experts en « Loi Juive »), et
ce tribunal le condamne pour blasphème après
l’avoir interrogé sur sa prétention à
être un messie. Il est alors transféré
devant le gouverneur romain, Ponce Pilate.
Celui-ci valide la condamnation à mort afin
de ne pas créer de trouble social, mais il
dit « je m’en lave les mains », c’est-à-dire
« je ne suis pas responsable du sort de cet
homme ».
* La crucifixion de Jésus : Jésus est crucifié
le jour même, un vendredi, sur le Golgotha,
une colline située à l’extérieur de Jérusalem.
* La résurrection de Jésus : deux jours
plus tard, le dimanche, des femmes venues
au tombeau pour laver et embaumer le corps
découvrent le tombeau vide. La thèse de
la résurrection s’impose avec la multiplication
des apparitions de Jésus, qui tient le même
langage et accomplit des miracles.
Après cette résurrection, les disciples
de Jésus le dotent définitivement d’une
identité surnaturelle et l’élèvent au-dessus
des prophètes : « Jésus » devient « Jésus-Christ
», c’est-à-dire Jésus le messie (le grec
Christos signifie le messie).
Quelle est la « philosophie » de Jésus
?
La philosophie de Jésus n’est pas entièrement
« neuve ». En effet, comme d’autres grandes
figures religieuses (ou spirituelles) — par
exemple Bouddha, ou Zoroastre, le prophète
fondateur du zoroastrisme, dont je vous parlerai
dans les prochaines leçons — comme ces
figures, Jésus renouvelle en partie les sagesses
antérieures.
Pour faire simple, sa philosophie peut être
résumée en 7 points :
1. L’amour — C’est le principal précepte
de Jésus. Il faut non seulement aimer Dieu,
mais il faut aussi aimer « son prochain », c’est-à-dire
tous les hommes, quels qu’ils soient, de
manière inconditionnelle.
« Tu aimeras ton prochain comme toi-même.
»
— Évangile selon Matthieu
2. L’égalité — Jésus considère que
tous les êtres humains sont égaux en tant
que fils de Dieu. À maintes reprises, il
rappelle l’égalité entre tous, pauvres
et riches, hommes et femmes, justes et pécheurs.
3. La liberté — Jésus refuse l’idée
d’un quelconque déterminisme social, familial,
ethnique ou religieux, et même d’une fatalité
qui interdirait à des individus de choisir
la voie du salut qu’il propose.
4. Le pardon — Jésus reconnaît à chacun
le droit à l’erreur et la possibilité
d’effacer cette erreur sans être jugé
ni condamné. Le pardon doit être inconditionnel.
5. La charité — Jésus appelle inlassablement
à la charité, c’est-à-dire au souci du
prochain. Il ne dénonce pas l’argent en
tant que tel, mais l’amour de l’argent,
à l’encontre duquel il recommande le partage.
6. La non-violence — Jésus exige de répondre
à la violence par la non-violence. Dans le
détail, il refuse la loi du talion exprimée
sous la formule « œil pour œil, dent pour
dent » dans la Torah, et il préconise lui,
selon la célèbre formule, de « tendre l’autre
joue », c’est-à-dire de ne pas répondre
à une insulte.
« Si quelqu’un te frappe sur la joue droite,
tends-lui aussi l’autre. »
— Évangile selon Matthieu
7. L’autonomie individuelle — Jésus pose
que toute personne humaine mérite le respect,
en vertu de quoi un individu est un être
autonome et responsable.
Ces 7 points sont toujours importants dans
le christianisme du XXIe siècle, mais il
y a bien sûr eu un écart entre, d’un côté,
la philosophie authentique de Jésus, et de
l’autre les dogmes construits ultérieurement
par les Églises chrétiennes.
Comment le christianisme se diffuse-t-il ?
Nous ne sommes pas certains que Jésus avait
l’intention de fonder une nouvelle religion.
Pour certains, il a seulement voulu revenir
aux fondements du judaïsme.
Mais trois de ses gestes ont fondé, par leur
charge symbolique, son Église :
1. le baptême unique (qu’il a reçu, lui,
de Jean-Baptiste), et qu’il aurait demandé
à ses apôtres de perpétuer après sa résurrection
;
2. la fraction du pain et le partage du vin
(lors de la Cène, le dernier repas avant
son arrestation), geste qu’il aurait demandé
à sa communauté de perpétuer en sa mémoire
(c’est l’eucharistie, dont je vous ai
parlé dans la 1ère leçon) ;
3. l’évangélisation par les 12 apôtres
: Jésus confie à ses plus proches disciples
la mission de diffuser sa parole dans toutes
les nations.
C’est donc le troisième geste qui enclenche
la diffusion du christianisme.
Dans les semaines qui suivent la crucifixion,
les apôtres parlent du Christ aux Juifs qui
viennent au Temple de Jérusalem. Ils fondent
dans cette même ville une Église, du grec
ekklesia qui signifie « assemblée de citoyens
». Cette Église réunit de petits groupes
de Juifs qui partagent un repas le dimanche
pour commémorer la Résurrection. Elle réussit
à convertir des pèlerins, lesquels fonderont
donc en rentrant chez eux de nouvelles communautés
chrétiennes.
Après la destruction du second temple par
les Romains en 70, la nouvelle Église rompt
avec le judaïsme. Le christianisme est désormais
ouvert aux non-Juifs et la mixité (entre
Juifs et non-Juifs) devient la règle. Il
se diffuse en Judée, sa région source, mais
également à Rome. Sur le plan pratique,
il s’organise : chaque communauté est placée
sous la responsabilité d’un Ancien ; et
un évêque gère la vie religieuse dans chaque
région.
Le début de la structuration de l’Église
est aussi le début des persécutions. Les
chrétiens ne bénéficient plus du statut
spécial accordé par l’Empire romain aux
Juifs, qui jouissaient ainsi d’une certaine
liberté de culte. La première persécution,
et une des plus connues, est celle commise
par l’empereur Néron au début de la seconde
moitié du Ier siècle. En voici l’épisode
phare : après le grand incendie de Rome de
64, dont certains disent qu’il en est à
l’origine, Néron accuse les chrétiens,
les fait arrêter et les torturer en public
de diverses manières (c’étaient de véritables
spectacles). Les persécutions ont donné
naissance au culte des martyrs, c’est-à-dire
des personnes qui préfèrent supporter une
immense souffrance plutôt que de renoncer
à leur foi. Contrairement à ce qu’escomptaient
les autorités romaines, ces exemples édifiants
ont renforcé la nouvelle religion.
Le christianisme s’impose dans l’Empire
romain au IVe siècle. En 313, il est reconnu
par les autorités impériales et accède
même au rang de religion privilégiée. L’Église,
déjà riche des dons de ses fidèles parmi
l’élite sociale, bénéficie en plus de
dotations de l’empereur Constantin, ce qui
permet de construire des basiliques à Rome.
L’évêque de la ville, qui jouit d’une
grande influence sur toute la chrétienté,
s’appelle désormais le « pape » (mot
qui vient du grec pappas, qui signifie « père
»). L’empire romain se christianise, au
point qu’en 391 l’empereur Théodose Ier
fait du christianisme la religion d’État
(interdisant par là même les autres cultes).
Trois siècles après les premières persécutions,
les idées des persécutés ont conquis l’empire
romain… et légitiment des persécutions.
Que retenir de la Bible chrétienne ?
Je vais d’abord vous expliquer comment la
Bible chrétienne a été constituée. Je
vous parlerai ensuite du contenu du Nouveau
Testament, qui comprend les Évangiles « canoniques
» (c’est-à-dire ceux qui ont été retenus
par l’Église) et 5 autres parties.
Comment a-t-elle été constituée ?
La constitution de la Bible chrétienne, le
livre de référence de la religion chrétienne,
est l’aboutissement de la constitution d’une
orthodoxie. En pratique, un ensemble d’idées
chrétiennes ont gagné en autorité jusqu’à
ne plus tolérer la concurrence des autres
idées. Leur mise par écrit concrétise leur
« victoire ». Naturellement, le processus
a duré pendant l’enfance de la religion
chrétienne, c’est-à-dire les premiers
siècles.
À la fin du IIe siècle naissent les premières
écoles de théologie, où sont élaborées
des idées fondamentales, comme l’identité
de Dieu et du Christ, ou encore l’obscur
concept (obscur à mes yeux) du Logos chrétien,
qui exprime grosso modo la puissance de la
parole divine. Les débats théologiques se
multiplient au fur et à mesure que le christianisme
se diffuse, et les fidèles s’enflamment
pour l’une ou l’autre des thèses qui
pullulent. C’est l’Église de Rome, qui
s’est imposée comme l’autorité de référence,
qui tranche les débats : elle valide par
exemple la doctrine (elle aussi bien obscure)
de la Trinité, selon laquelle le Père (Dieu),
le Fils (le Christ) et le Saint-Esprit (le
souffle divin) sont une seule et même essence
divine ; mais dans le même temps l’Église
de Rome condamne et excommunie les hérétiques.
Comment la doctrine « officielle » est-elle
mise par écrit ?
Il est difficile de répondre avec précision.
C’est un processus progressif au cours des
premiers siècles. En même temps qu’ils
sont transmis par la tradition, l’histoire
de Jésus et les enseignements de ses disciples
sont mis par écrit par différentes personnes.
Au fur et à mesure émerge, probablement
à partir du IIe siècle, l’idée d’élaborer
ce qu’on appelle un « canon », c’est-à-dire
de lister les écrits qui ont une valeur sacrée.
Ils sont regroupés dans ce que les chrétiens
appellent le « Nouveau Testament » (écrit
en grec), ce qui les amène à appeler la
Bible hébraïque « Ancien Testament ». L’étymologie
gréco-latine du mot « testament » combine
2 idées révélatrices : 1° le témoignage
(La Bible est un témoignage à propos de
l’histoire de Jésus et de ses disciples),
et 2° le contrat (La Bible est aussi un contrat
entre la divinité et les hommes). Ainsi,
ces deux testaments, l’ancien et le nouveau,
forment la Bible du christianisme.
Cependant, la liste des textes à y compiler
fait débat. Le canon de l’Ancien Testament,
c’est-à-dire la version chrétienne de
la Bible hébraïque, est arrêté vers la
fin du Ier siècle. Quant à celui du Nouveau
Testament, il est arrêté en 364 au concile
de Laodicée (au sud-ouest de la Turquie actuelle).
Cela signifie que lorsque les évêques, le
top management de l’Église catholique de
l’époque, se sont réunis en assemblée
— le latin concilium veut dire « assemblée
» — à Laodicée pour décider de questions
de doctrine, de morale ou de discipline, ils
ont notamment décidé de faire le « casting
» définitif des textes qui méritent de
figurer dans le Nouveau Testament, et de ceux
qui ne le méritent pas.
Cela signifie logiquement qu’il existe d’autres
textes religieux chrétiens que ceux que l’on
trouve dans La Bible : on les appelle « apocryphes
» (du grec apokruphos, «
tenu secret, non lu dans les églises »). Il
existe par exemple des « évangiles apocryphes
» : la plupart ont été conservés et sont
aujourd’hui édités en livres de poche.
Ils rapportent des paroles oubliées de Jésus,
donnent des détails sur sa vie, ou racontent
son séjour chez les morts.
Enfin, sachez que l’adjectif « apocryphe
» qualifie plus généralement un document
dont l’authenticité n’est pas établie
(par exemple, une lettre apocryphe).
Que sont les Évangiles ?
Les Évangiles sont la 1ère des 6 parties
du Nouveau Testament. Ce sont les textes de
référence où les premiers chrétiens ont
rapporté la vie et le message de Jésus-Christ.
Le mot « évangile » vient du grec euaggelion
qui signifie « bonne nouvelle ». L’idée
est donc que Jésus-Christ est venu annoncer
aux hommes une bonne nouvelle, en l’occurrence
celle du salut, c’est-à-dire que les hommes
vont être sauvés par la bonté de Dieu.
Dans un sens plus précis, le mot « évangile
» désigne un ouvrage dans lequel est rapportée
la bonne nouvelle en question, à travers
la vie et le message de Jésus-Christ. Enfin,
il signifie de manière figurée, justement
par référence à l’autorité des Évangiles
pour les chrétiens, une vérité tenue pour
indubitable. Lorsque je dis, par exemple,
« ce que lui raconte son père est pour lui
parole d’Évangile », cela signifie que
le fils croit fermement à ce que lui raconte
son père.
« Le socialisme est l’évangile de la jalousie.
»
— Winston Churchill
Le Nouveau Testament comprend 4 Évangiles
dit « canoniques » :
1. celui de l’apôtre Matthieu ;
2. celui de Marc, un proche de l’apôtre
Pierre, qui sera le guide et le principal
porte-parole de la première communauté chrétienne
;
3. celui de l’apôtre Luc, qui était médecin
4. celui de l’apôtre Jean.
Pour les retenir plus facilement, vous pouvez
remarquer que l’ordre dans lequel ils sont
rangés dans la Bible est l’ordre alphabétique
inversé : MAT - MAR - L - J.
Les 3 premiers Évangiles sont dits « synoptiques
» (du grec sunopsis, qui signifie « vue
d’ensemble »), parce qu’ils se ressemblent
et qu’ils présentent l'histoire et l'enseignement
de Jésus selon des plans comparables. Le
plus ancien, l’Évangile selon Marc, a été
composé alors que des témoins directs des
événements étaient encore en vie ; ceux
de Matthieu et de Luc auraient été écrits
entre 80 et 90.
En revanche, l’Évangile selon Jean aurait
été rédigé plus tardivement, vers l’an
100, soit au moins 60 ans après les faits
qu’il décrit. C’est un Évangile atypique,
formé de grands discours (plutôt que de
courtes paraboles comme les synoptiques),
et il développe également des thèmes inédits,
plus spirituels, comme celui de la vie éternelle.
Que retenir des autres parties du Nouveau
Testament ?
Voici les 5 autres parties du Nouveau Testament
:
1. Les Actes des Apôtres racontent les débuts
de la communauté chrétienne. On y trouve
notamment le récit de la prédication de
saint Paul, une des figures majeures, sinon
LA figure majeure de la diffusion du christianisme
des origines. Saint Paul est un personnage
particulier, car il a d’abord persécuté
les disciples de Jésus, avant de se convertir
sur le chemin de Damas — ce qui donnera
l’expression « chemin de Damas », qui
désigne un événement qui entraîne un brusque
changement d’opinion — et de revendiquer
le statut d’apôtre.
2. Les Épîtres de Paul sont 13 lettres écrites
par saint Paul aux communautés chrétiennes
de l’époque. Il y développe et précise
la doctrine chrétienne, ou bien il traite
de l’actualité et de l’organisation des
communautés.
« Ne vous y trompez pas : les mauvaises compagnies
corrompent les bonnes mœurs. »
— Saint Paul, Épître aux Corinthiens
3. L’Épître aux Hébreux n’est pas vraiment
une lettre, et elle n’est pas forcément
adressée aux Hébreux (contrairement à ce
qu’indique le titre). C’est un texte divisé
en 13 chapitres qui traite notamment du rôle
de Jésus-Christ.
4. Les Épîtres catholiques sont des lettres
faussement attribuées aux auteurs auxquels
renvoient leurs titres. Sur le fond, elles
servent à préciser la doctrine et à solidifier
la foi des communautés chrétiennes de l’époque
(par exemple pour les empêcher de retourner
au judaïsme).
5. L’Apocalypse de saint Jean décrit la
vision (« apocalypse » signifie étymologiquement
« révélation ») de l’apôtre Jean (mais
les historiens ne sont pas certains de l’identité
de l’auteur). Ce que voit Jean, c’est
l’affrontement à la fin des temps entre
Dieu et Satan et la victoire finale de Dieu,
après une série de jugements contre l’humanité
révoltée contre lui. Sur le plan littéraire,
le texte est très différent du reste du
Nouveau Testament : il y a beaucoup de symboles
; les scènes sont grandioses et dramatiques
; le contenu est, au global, étrange et énigmatique.
« Heureux celui qui lit et ceux qui entendent
les paroles de la prophétie, et qui gardent
les choses qui y sont écrites ! Car le temps
est proche. »
— Apocalypse de saint Jean
Quelles sont les évolutions marquantes du
christianisme ?
Les évolutions les plus marquantes du christianisme
sont les grands schismes de son histoire,
les croisades et l’Inquisition, la victoire
de la laïcité (en France), et enfin la modernisation
de la religion catholique au XXe siècle.
Quels sont les grands schismes de l’histoire
du christianisme ?
Comme on l’a vu dans le 1er module à propos
de la taille des communautés humaines, plus
un groupe s’agrandit, plus son unité est
menacée. La religion chrétienne a naturellement
dû faire face à de telles menaces au fur
et à mesure qu’elle se diffusait.
Le mot « schisme » vient du grec skhisma,
qui signifie « fente, séparation ». Il
désigne donc la sécession d’un groupe
de fidèles qui ne reconnaît plus l’autorité
de l’Église.
Les 3 principales branches du christianisme
sont nées de 2 schismes majeurs :
1. le schisme d’Orient, dont naîtra l’Église
orthodoxe ;
2. le schisme protestant, dont est né le
protestantisme.
Le schisme d’Orient est l’aboutissement
d’un conflit ancien. Au début du Ve siècle,
la chute de l’Empire romain d’Occident
divise déjà clairement le christianisme
en 2 zones. D’un côté, l’Église Occident
est sous l’autorité du pape ; de l’autre
côté, en Orient, l’autorité est répartie
entre 4 villes, Constantinople (l’actuelle
Istanbul), Alexandrie (Égypte), Antioche
(au sud de la Turquie), et Jérusalem. Quant
aux Églises situées hors de l’empire romain,
elles deviendront progressivement autonomes.
La rupture finale se produit au XIe siècle.
Les désaccords entre l’Église d’Orient
et l’Église d’Occident se multiplient,
et le schisme devient inéluctable après
une nouvelle querelle — une querelle fondamentale,
vous allez voir — autour du pain de la communion
: Rome exige un pain non levé, Constantinople
un pain levé. S’ensuit donc un anathème
réciproque des 2 Églises en 1054, c’est-à-dire
que chaque Église déclare que l’autre
ne fait plus partie de la communauté des
fidèles. Si les relations sont toutefois
maintenues, elles cessent pour de bon après
le sac de Constantinople par les croisés
en 1204.
Les 2 Églises suivent alors des voies différentes.
Rome réunit sous sa tutelle tous les diocèses,
c’est-à-dire toutes les circonscriptions
chrétiennes d’Occident. En revanche, Constantinople
reconnaît l’autonomie des patriarcats qui
deviennent de plus en plus « nationaux », liés
aux États dont ils relèvent. Ces Églises
orientales revendiquent, par leur nom d’«
orthodoxes », leur attachement à la « juste
» doctrine. L’Église d’Occident, elle,
choisit l’appellation de « catholique », du
grec katholikos, qui signifie « universel
».
Vous connaissez l’essentiel concernant le
schisme d’Orient. Je vous parlerai du schisme
protestant (qui interviendra au XVIe siècle)
dans la leçon consacrée au protestantisme.
Que retenir des croisades et de l’Inquisition
?
Les croisades et l’Inquisition sont les
deux meilleurs exemples de la violation manifeste,
par l’Église, de l’enseignement d’amour
et de non-violence du Christ.
Les croisades sont les expéditions menées
par les chrétiens au Moyen Âge afin de libérer
le tombeau du Christ à Jérusalem. Et le
mot « croisade » désigne, par extension,
une campagne menée pour défendre une cause
(on peut parler, par exemple, de « la croisade
pour l’abolition de la peine de mort »).
À partir du IXe siècle, les papes multiplient
les appels à lutter contre les infidèles.
Et pour motiver les guerriers, ils leur promettent
que leurs péchés seront intégralement pardonnés
dans l’au-delà. À la fin de l’année
1095, alors qu’évêques, abbés, rois et
princes d’Europe sont réunis à Clermont,
le pape Urbain II lance un appel à la croisade
pour sauver les chrétiens d’Orient et délivrer
Jérusalem des infidèles. Les foules se précipitent
d’abord pour répondre à l’appel. Les
partants prononcent un vœu indélébile sous
peine d’excommunication, en échange duquel
le salut éternel leur est garanti.
« Dieu le veut »
— Urbain II en 1095
Les armées chrétiennes prennent Jérusalem
en 1099. Seulement, les contre-offensives
des armées musulmanes nécessiteront d’autres
croisades : 8 au total seront organisées
entre 1095 et 1270. Mais la plupart sont des
échecs cuisants, car la ferveur des fidèles
s’est nettement essoufflée à partir de
la 5ème (au début du XIIIe siècle).
Que retenir de l’Inquisition, maintenant
?
En même temps qu’elle combat les infidèles,
l’Église lutte contre les hérésies, c’est-à-dire
les versions du christianisme concurrentes
de la sienne. C’est dans cette optique qu’est
lancé le projet de l’Inquisition par le
pape Grégoire IX en 1232. Aucun grand théologien
ne s’oppose au cauchemar qui s’inaugure.
« Les hérétiques méritent d’être retranchés
du monde par la mort. »
— Thomas d’Aquin, Somme théologique
Le pape autorise les inquisiteurs, des prêtres
ou des moines, à pratiquer la torture par
« amour et miséricorde » jusqu’à faire
avouer les accusés. Les institutions de l’Inquisition
servent notamment la conversion des populations
des Amériques à partir du XVe siècle, ce
qui était la condition pour que les colons
deviennent propriétaires des terres conquises.
Elles légitiment ainsi un véritable génocide,
ce que dénonce le missionnaire espagnol Bartolomé
de las Casas dans sa Très brève relation
de la destruction des Indes (ce livre fera
de lui le premier défenseur, historiquement,
des Indiens opprimés). L’inquisition la
plus redoutable est celle qui se poursuivra
en Espagne jusqu’au milieu du XVIIIe siècle
: elle s’est permis de juger des non-catholiques
et elle a soumis à la torture environ la
moitié des accusés.
Comment la laïcité s’est-elle imposée
en France ?
Le mot « laïcité » vient du latin laicus,
qui signifie « ordinaire » (par opposition
à ce qui est religieux ou spirituel). Pour
faire simple, la laïcité signifie la neutralité
à l’égard de toutes les confessions. Après,
on peut préciser et appliquer cette idée
de diverses manières, c’est pourquoi il
y a encore et toujours, en France, un débat
sur la définition même du concept, où s’opposent
diverses visions de la laïcité.
La victoire de la laïcité est l’aboutissement
d’une longue évolution. À la fin du Moyen
Âge, la pensée commence à s’émanciper
du christianisme (comme on l’a vu dans le
module de culture philosophique). Sur le plan
politique, dans le même temps, le pouvoir
royal français limite l’ingérence du pape
dans la vie religieuse du pays, ce que concrétise
le Concordat de Bologne de 1516, qui donne
au roi un pouvoir sur l’Église de France.
« La laïcité, un lent travail des siècles.
»
— Ferdinand Buisson, premier théoricien
de la laïcité
L’autorité du dogme chrétien recule progressivement
au cours de la Renaissance, de l’âge classique,
des Lumières, et du XIXe siècle, qui est
probablement celui qui voit l’autorité
de la science supplanter celle de la religion.
Sur le plan politique, la laïcité s’impose
par 2 ruptures :
1. la Révolution Française met fin à une
monarchie de droit divin, en vertu de quoi
la France ne se perçoit plus comme « la
fille ainée de l’Eglise » ;
2. la loi de 1905 de séparation des Églises
et de l'État, la clé de voûte de la laïcité
en France — cette loi proclame la liberté
de conscience, garantit le libre exercice
des cultes et met en place un nouveau régime
des cultes.
La laïcité devient ensuite un principe fondamental
de la République française. En effet, l’article
1 de la Constitution de 1958 (actuellement
en vigueur) dit que « la France est une République
indivisible, LAÏQUE, démocratique et sociale
». La seule limite actuelle au principe de
laïcité est le respect de l’ordre public.
Cependant, la laïcité est un concept évolutif.
Il n’est pas figé dans son acception originelle,
car il se nourrit des transformations de la
société. Les décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
permettent par exemple de préciser les applications
de la laïcité.
Comment le christianisme s’est-il modernisé
?
L’adaptation du christianisme au monde dans
lequel vivent ses fidèles n’est pas seulement
une réaction à la sécularisation. C’est
un processus perpétuel par lequel l’Église,
comme tout pouvoir, préserve son autorité
en entretenant le consentement des individus
qui la reconnaissent. Plus la société évolue,
et plus elle évolue rapidement, plus la religion
doit s’adapter. C’est pourquoi le XXe
siècle, où l’Occident a connu des transformations
sans précédent, a nécessité une modernisation
de l’Église catholique.
L’événement qui symbolise cette modernisation
est le concile Vatican II. Pendant 3 ans à
partir de 1962, quelque 2400 évêques venus
du monde entier se réunissent pour se mettre
d’accord sur une évolution de la doctrine
et des institutions. Les conservateurs, pourtant
minioritaires, et les progressistes se livrent
à un combat qui dure jusqu’à la fin du
concile. L’Église catholique en ressortira
profondément renouvelée et rajeunie.
En voici, en synthèse, les décisions marquantes
:
* la suppression du latin dans la messe ;
* la reconnaissance du rôle des laïcs (c’est-à-dire
ceux qui ne consacrent pas leur vie à la
religion) dans l’Église ;
* la restauration d’un gouvernement plus
collectif de l’Église par les évêques
;
* la promotion de la lecture de la Bible par
les fidèles (ce que les autorités catholiques
préféraient éviter depuis la Réforme protestante)
;
* la reconnaissance de la liberté religieuse
de tous les hommes ;
* la condamnation de la guerre (au premier
chef de la guerre nucléaire) ;
* l’invitation à oublier les dissensions
et inimitiés du passé avec les musulmans
;
* l’affirmation selon laquelle les Juifs
ne sont pas responsables de la mort du Christ
et la condamnation de l’antisémitisme.
Si le concile de Vatican II a d’abord suscité
l’euphorie dans le monde catholique, il
a ensuite été l’objet de vives critiques.
D’un côté, les catholiques conservateurs
en ont refusé autant l’esprit que les conclusions
; de l’autre côté, les progressistes ont
trouvé que l’évolution était insuffisante
(par exemple, les évêques ont laissé de
côté les questions de la contraception,
du célibat des prêtres, ou encore de l’accès
des femmes à la prêtrise).
Qui sont les penseurs majeurs du christianisme
?
Je vais vous parler des penseurs qu’on appelle
les « Pères de l’Église » ; de saint
Augustin ; de Thomas d’Aquin ; et des papes
les plus importants.
Qui sont les Pères de l'Église ?
Les Pères de l’Église sont, parmi les
premiers théologiens chrétiens, ceux dont
la vie et la pensée ont contribué à défendre
la doctrine chrétienne.
Pour accéder à ce statut, il faut répondre
à 4 conditions :
1. avoir vécu au cours des premiers siècles
du christianisme (avant le Ve siècle) ;
2. avoir mené une vie exemplaire ;
3. avoir créé une œuvre exemplaire sur
le plan doctrinal (c’est-à-dire en tout
point conforme à la version du christianisme
de l’Église) ;
4. avoir été soutenu par l’Église.
On distingue différentes générations de
Pères de l’Église :
* Les plus anciens sont appelés « Pères
apostoliques » parce qu’ils ont été contemporains
des apôtres. Vous pouvez retenir le nom de
​​Clément de Rome, un des premiers successeurs
de l’apôtre Pierre (Clément de Rome est
officiellement considéré comme le 4ème
pape de l’histoire de l’Église).
* La génération suivante a notamment défendu
les chrétiens contre les persécutions, à
l’image de Justin de Naplouse, un philosophe
chrétien du IIe siècle.
* À la même époque, certaines Pères s’illustrent
en combattant la gnose chrétienne, c’est-à-dire
une version du christianisme dans laquelle
l’individu doit faire lui-même l’effort
de connaître les choses divines (le mot « gnose
» vient du grec gnosis, qui signifie « connaissance
»). Saint Irénée est le représentant le
plus actif de la réaction orthodoxe contre
les gnostiques.
* À partir du IIIe siècle, les Pères de
l’Église s’illustrent dans la consolidation
du dogme dans de véritables écoles de théologie.
Tertullien, le plus éminent théologien de
Carthage (au nord-est de l’actuelle Tunisie),
est l’auteur de l’idée de la Trinité.
* L’épanouissement littéraire du IVe siècle,
lié à la fin des persécutions, donne à
l’Église des Pères de diverses tendances.
Ceux du monde latin, appelés les « Pères
latins », sont moins originaux que ceux du
monde grec, mais ils comptent parmi eux un
des plus célèbres Pères de l’Église,
saint Augustin.
* L’âge des Pères de l’Église se referme
au Ve siècle, où l’Empire romain se désagrège
sous le coup des invasions barbares.
Qu’apporte saint Augustin à la doctrine
chrétienne ?
Je vous ai déjà parlé de saint Augustin
à propos de la philosophie chrétienne, à
la fin de la leçon intitulée « Les autres
philosophies de l’Antiquité ». Je vous
rappelle que c’est un théologien romain
des IVe et Ve siècles après J.-C.
L’essentiel à retenir pour votre connaissance
du christianisme, c’est que saint Augustin
a joué un rôle décisif dans l'élaboration
d’une culture chrétienne en Occident.
Son apport décisif à la doctrine est la
notion de péché originel. Dans la théorie
de saint Augustin, le péché commis par Adam
et Ève (dans la Genèse, ils mangent le fruit
défendu de l'arbre de la connaissance du
bien et du mal) — ce péché retombe sur
toute l’humanité, de telle sorte que tout
homme naît en état de péché. C’est pour
cette raison que le baptême est un rite important,
car il permet d’effacer le péché originel.
Saint Augustin a également développé les
concepts chrétiens de la prédestination
et de l’amour, comme je vous l’ai expliqué
dans le module de culture philosophique.
« Nul ne pèche par un acte qu'il ne peut
éviter. »
— Saint Augustin, Traité du libre arbitre
Qu’apporte Thomas d’Aquin à la doctrine
chrétienne ?
Je vous ai déjà parlé de Thomas d’Aquin
à propos des grands philosophes du Moyen
Âge.
Je vous rappelle que c’est un religieux
italien du XIIIe siècle, probablement le
plus célèbre penseur de la philosophie et
de la théologie scolastiques (c’est-à-dire
produites par le système académique lié
à l’Église médiévale).
Son apport décisif à la doctrine chrétienne
est la conciliation de la raison et de la
foi. Inspiré à la fois par saint Augustin
et par Aristote, Thomas d’Aquin définit
la foi par deux conditions : 1° adhérer
à la parole de Dieu, et 2° croire que la
raison est la lumière naturelle émanant
de Dieu (et qu’elle sert à éclairer les
hommes). Autrement dit, avoir la foi demande
aussi d’avoir foi en la raison, conçue
comme une faculté divine.
« Chaque homme, par sa nature même, possède
innée en lui
la lumière de la raison qui dirige ses actes
vers sa fin. »
— Thomas d’Aquin, Somme théologique
Qui sont les papes les plus importants ?
Le pape est l'évêque de Rome et le chef
de l'Église catholique. Il est élu après
la mort ou la renonciation de son prédécesseur,
et son autorité se transmet par succession
depuis l'apôtre Pierre lui-même, qui l'a
reçue directement de Jésus-Christ. 266 papes
se sont succédé depuis Pierre, fondateur
de l'Église. En tant que représentants suprêmes
de l'Église catholique, ils ont une grande
influence qui leur permet d’infléchir la
doctrine chrétienne.
Voici 3 papes qui ont changé le visage du
christianisme :
1° Léon XIII est appelé « le pape des
ouvriers ».
Il a dirigé l’Église de 1878 à 1903.
Je vous ai déjà parlé de lui dans le module
de culture économique, à propos de la contestation
des idées néoclassiques. Il est important
parce qu’il a élaboré ce qu’on appelle
la « doctrine sociale de l’Église catholique
».
Le texte de référence de cette doctrine
est l’encyclique Rerum novarum (« les choses
nouvelles » en français) de 1891. Léon
XIII y propose des solutions à la montée
de la question sociale. Il renvoie dos à
dos les libéraux et les socialistes athées
en les accusant de réduire la relation sociale
au conflit, et il invite lui patrons et ouvriers
à mettre en pratique la conception chrétienne
de la coopération afin de prévenir les excès
du capitalisme. Mais les mots durs qu’il
a contre les patrons le font passer pour un
défenseur des ouvriers.
Il dénonce par exemple…
« …la concentration entre les mains de
quelques-uns de l'industrie et du commerce,
devenus le partage d'un petit nombre d'hommes
opulents et de ploutocrates,
qui imposent ainsi un joug presque servile
à l'infinie multitude des prolétaires. »
— Léon XIII, Rerum novarum
2° Jean XXIII, qui a dirigé l’Église
de 1958 à 1963, est l’initiateur de Vatican
II.
Autrement dit, il est à l’origine de la
modernisation du catholicisme au XXe siècle.
Lorsqu’il a ouvert le concile en 1962, il
souhaitait adapter l’Église aux besoins
du monde moderne, lui donner un discours compréhensible
pour des chrétiens contemporains, et rendre
au message chrétien sa profondeur en revenant
à la source des paroles du Christ.
À un responsable du Vatican qui avait affirmé
qu’il était « absolument impossible » d’ouvrir
le concile Vatican II en 1963, il avait répondu
:
« Bien. Nous l’ouvrirons en 1962 »
— Jean XXIII
Il ne verra pas le résultat de son initiative,
car il meurt 8 mois après l’ouverture des
travaux. Censé être un pape de transition
parce qu’il n’était pas un candidat évident
et en raison de son âge (72 ans), il a pourtant
marqué l’histoire de l’Église catholique.
3° Jean-Paul II a été un des hommes les
plus influents du XXe siècle.
Il a dirigé l’Église pendant presque 30
ans, de 1978 à 2005. Il a énormément voyagé
à travers le monde afin de promouvoir la
paix, les droits de l’Homme et la liberté
religieuse. Son opposition à l’idéologie
communiste (notamment en Pologne, sa patrie)
a favorisé la chute du bloc de l’Est, et
il a œuvré en faveur du rapprochement des
religions.
« Le communisme en tant que système s’est
révélé un remède
plus dangereux que la maladie elle-même.
»
— Jean-Paul II
Enfin, Jean-Paul II a survécu à une tentative
d’assassinat en 1981. Il a pardonné au
jeune Turc qui avait tiré sur lui, mais après
cet épisode, il circulait dans les foules
dans une voiture blindée surnommée la « papamobile
».
Quelle est la situation actuelle du christianisme
?
Je vais vous parler de la réalité démographique
du christianisme (dans le monde et en France),
ainsi que de l’évolution actuelle de cette
religion.
Combien y a-t-il de chrétiens ?
Au début du XXIe siècle, le monde compte
grosso modo 2 milliards de chrétiens, dont
1,1 milliard de catholiques (55 %), 650 millions
de protestants (un tiers), et 230 millions
d’orthodoxes (un peu plus de 10 %).
La fiabilité de ces chiffres est cependant
relative, car :
* ils ne proviennent pas d’un recensement
planétaire ;
* ils ne prennent pas en compte le taux de
pratique des fidèles ;
* ils ne prennent pas non plus en compte leur
degré de croyance.
Dans le détail, les places fortes du christianisme
se sont déplacées :
* les chrétiens d’Europe et des États-Unis,
noyau dur du christianisme à la fin du XIXe
siècle, ne représentent plus qu’un gros
quart des fidèles ;
* l’Amérique latine compte 40 % des catholiques
dans le monde ;
* 40 % des Africains sont chrétiens (catholiques,
protestants, ou ce qu’on appelle « afro-chrétiens
», c’est-à-dire adeptes d’un mélange
de christianisme et de croyances locales,
comme le culte des ancêtres) ;
* l’Asie compte plus de 300 millions de
chrétiens, et le principal bastion du continent
est les Philippines, à 90 % chrétiennes
(avec une très forte majorité catholique).
En France, les catholiques représentent aujourd’hui
environ ⅓ de la population, contre environ
les ¾ à la fin des Trente Glorieuses. Et
ce déclin démographique dissimule encore
le déclin de la pratique : seul 1 Français
sur 15 (environ) se rend à la messe au moins
une fois par mois à la fin des années 2010.
Comment la religion chrétienne semble-t-elle
évoluer ?
Le déplacement des places fortes est révélateur
de l’évolution la plus importante de la
religion chrétienne : l’effondrement du
christianisme européen. Seuls quelques pays
comme la Grèce orthodoxe ou la Pologne catholique
résistent à ce déclin.
L’effondrement se constate tout d’abord
au niveau des institutions. En effet, malgré
l’important effort d’adaptation que représente
le concile Vatican II, les institutions chrétiennes
— catholiques, notamment — ont perdu leur
autorité et leur rôle dans la vie des fidèles.
Les statistiques de l’Église catholique
concernant les différents rites (baptêmes,
mariages, etc.) en France confirment la forte
baisse de la pratique religieuse : à très
gros traits, l’intensité de la pratique
a été divisée au moins par deux (c’est
parfois plus) entre la fin des Trente Glorieuses
et les années 2010. En outre, les ordinations,
les consécrations de nouveaux prêtres, ont
aussi fortement chuté : en France, le nombre
de prêtres catholiques a été divisé par
deux de la fin des années 1990 à la fin
des années 2010.
L’effondrement se constate ensuite au niveau
des croyances. Les sondages montrent que les
Occidentaux sont devenus profondément sceptiques
: ils ne sont pas certains que Dieu existe
; ils jugent qu’il y a du vrai dans toutes
les religions ; ils doutent de l’efficacité
de pratiques comme la prière ; ou encore,
ils ne sont plus attirés par la quête du
bonheur dans l’au-delà, ils le veulent
maintenant et tout de suite.
Le fort recul de la religion catholique dans
la majorité de la population favorise, en
réaction, l’essor d’un christianisme
identitaire fondamentaliste. Chez les catholiques,
cette réaction s’exprime notamment à travers
ce qu’on appelle le « Renouveau charismatique
», un courant de renouveau spirituel né
peu après le concile Vatican II, comme il
y en eut d’autres au fil de l’histoire
de l’Église. Mais ce courant est inspiré
du pentecôtisme, un courant spirituel protestant
né aux États-Unis au début du XXe siècle.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.